we all loved the movie The Matrix and
the holodeck and the question is when
will we be able to enter a room and
create this imaginary scenarios so
realistic that it seems as if we're
really there it turns out that we
scientists are making progress in that
direction even as we speak
first of all in the future the internet
will be in your contact lens you will
blink and you will go online you will
see individuals and their biography will
appear and subtitles will appear if they
speak in Chinese so you will always know
who you're talking to and what they are
saying even if they speak in a different
language now think about this if you
have internet contact lenses then you
can imagine and conjure up different
kinds of bizarre universes just like in
the matrix you can be thrust into an
alien environment you could have
shootouts with aliens you could have all
sorts of wondrous things take place
inside your contact lens but then the
trick is what happens if you move what
happens to be touch things well the
military has constructed something
called omnidirectional treadmills
it's a treadmill in any direction now I
had a chance to take a film crew from
the Science Channel down to Fort Benning
Georgia where we filmed me inside the
omnidirectional treadmill I was
surrounded by 360-degree screens showing
the image of Baghdad I had a backpack
and then as I walked I could walk in any
direction and always wind up in the same
place but as I moved everything around
me moved the streets of Baghdad changed
every time I ran in any direction the
last thing that's missing is a sense of
touch
that's where haptic technology comes in
haptic technology is the ability to
create the feel of a virtual reality now
how does that work let's say you have a
platform with thousands of vertical pins
such that when you put your hand on this
platform the pins then conform to the
fingers because each pin is governed by
a computer therefore if you put your
hand on this set of pins
you can duplicate any texture that you
want so in some sense if you're
surrounded by these haptic devices
you'll be able to touch objects and
think that you were actually touching
skin or touching wood or touching metal
and then you have the Internet contact
lens and then you're surrounded by
360-degree screens with an
omnidirectional treadmill you're getting
awfully close to the matrix